it's a very significant announcement
because it makes it possible for the
Ukrainian both to defend themselves
against
new Russian offensives we know that they
are planning for that but also uh it
enables the ukrainians to get the combat
capabilities they need to be able to uh
liberate retake territory which is
currently occupied by Russian forces so
this these announcements about the
battle tanks are of great importance of
course numbers matters and therefore
welcomed that many allies have Medicaid
are ready to provide a battle thanks to
to Ukraine and and we've always started
uh looking into how we can provide
training uh how allies can provide
training uh and and get the bad times
delivered as quickly as possible
okay he did tell me this morning uh that
he doesn't know when those European
tanks will arrive on Ukrainian soil from
what you're saying what do you think is
the quickest timeline possible
I'll be careful going into exactly how
quick this can go but I know that the
Allies are extremely focused on uh the
importance of speed of getting a
training and the actual delivery
delivery of Battle Tanks as soon as
quick as possible and let me also
welcome the leadership to the United
Kingdom has demonstrated because the
United Kingdom actually several days ago
announced that they will deliver modern
NATO standard main battle tanks to
challenge a two battle tank and now all
their allies are following up with
additional announcements
yeah but are we talking days weeks
months before the end of the war
I was very careful going into exactly
how long time this will take but of
course it takes them some time to train
a cruise to be able to operate these
battle tanks at the same time we have
seen uh how capable how skilled the
Ukrainian uh uh soldiers personal are in
uh in learning how to operate a NATO
standard uh weapon systems so they're
from confident that this will go as fast
as possible and that allies will do
whatever they can to to make it as as
quick as possible and let me also remind
you that not only do we have the
announcements of Battle Tanks the UK
Germany and others but also but also
last week we had several NATO allies and
partners announcing a significant amount
of additional armored vehicles and
infantry fighting Vehicles so it is this
whole Spectrum this package of different
types of armor from infantry fighting
vehicles to battle tanks that all
together provides the ukrainians with a
significant strength and combat
capability that will be extremely
important in the in the in the
Mountainside
so President zielinski also wants a
long-range missiles and F-16 fighter
jets he says the Dutch cabinet I believe
has said that if asked they will
consider supplying him and that's what
the Dutch is saying the Germans have
only reluctantly agreed to license their
tanks are we seeing a fracturing in the
West's approach to the war in Ukraine
so what we see is an unprecedented level
of support and unity among NATO allies
and partners President Putin made at
least two big mistakes strategic
mistakes when he invaded Ukraine he
totally underestimated the Ukrainian the
Ukraine armed forces the Kurdish the
commitment but they also underestimated
NATO and the NATO allies and partners uh
when it comes to our commitment to
support Ukraine so we have delivered a
unprecedented level of Military Support
we are stepping up delivering even more
and of course
this is something which is appreciated
recognized by by the Ukrainian
leadership I I just spoke with president
zelensky and they welcomed the support
that has been given over a long period
of time and also the new announcements
of more heavier and and armored
capabilities today
then we will need to constantly assess
uh what more we should do and therefore
also welcome the close consultations
between NATO allies and partners on what
type of systems we should deliver what
more we can do and that will be an
ongoing process among allies as long as
this war lost
if I can add one more thing and that is
that we need to discussions but you also
need to ensure that all the systems we
have provided already have the
ammunition have the spare parts uh the
maintenance the need to operate as they
should because we have already delivered
a lot and this has really made a
difference on the battlefield already
okay so you're not ruling it out but
there's a long way to go uh a final
question if I may please um it's almost
a year as you know since the start of
the war in Ukraine President zielinski
telling me today that uh he is uh wary
of um new Russian surges coming very
soon certainly on the horizon how
worried should he be
we have no indication that President
Putin has changed his goals when it
comes to the War uh invasion of Ukraine
he he wants northern Europe he wants
Europe where he can control neighbors
and uh and control Ukraine and and
Russia is planning for new offensives
they are building heavily up they are
mobilized hundreds of thousands of new
troops uh ramping or production
acquiring ammunition from authoritarian
regimes like Iran
North Korea and and uh and therefore we
have to be prepared for a new Russian
offensives that's exactly why the
announcements made last week are so
important with more armor more
ammunitions more also long range
weapons like the high Mars but also the
new announcements of Battle Tanks so
it's urgent and that's the reason why I
welcome those important announcements
we appreciate you taking the time to
join us today thank you very much indeed
thank you so much for having me